maillard adra vous êtes journaliste et
membre fondateur du forum académique
chrétiens pour la citoyenneté dans le
monde arabe bonjour madame merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors on vient
de l'apprendre instant le parlement
vient d'accorder sa confiance au
gouvernement de hassan diab sachant
mêler donne pas il n'y a pas de surprise
évidemment parce que le quorum a été
atteint vers 11h45 aujourd'hui donc il y
avait une véritable volonté surtout chez
les blocs parlementaires qui appuient
hassan diab et qui sont les blocs je
dirais anti souverainiste vivent et qui
qui ont contribué beaucoup à la
corruption et à l'état délétère dans
lequel le pays patauge depuis plus de
cent jours et depuis plus de deux
décennies aussi je dirais donc cette
confiance aujourd'hui n'a aucune
validité sur un plan populaire sur le
plan populaire je pense que il ya un
véritable rejet de la classe politique
est un véritable rejet aussi du
parlement des plus grands blocs
parlementaires qui eux ont tout limité
le pouvoir ça soit économique politique
aussi dans leur parti donc évidemment
confiance au niveau du parlement mais
méfiance totale et pour moi je m'attends
à une escalade de violence aussi dans
les rues du liban
qu'est ce que l'on peut reprocher à
cette feuille de route qui a été
présentée aujourd'hui
oui aujourd'hui alors ce cette feuille
de route
elle n'est pas différente des feuilles
de route des différents gouvernements
qui ont failli à renflouer l'économie
libanaise et a relevé le liban de la
crise dans laquelle de laquelle il est
prisonnier en fait la feuille c'est
toujours la même on parle c'est le même
discours en bois les mêmes discours qui
n'évolue pas qu'ils ne proposent pas de
solutions qui sont plus littéraire que
pragmatique et je vais vous donner
quelques preuves donc le droit du peuple
libanais a résisté
ça se contredit totalement avec l'idée
tdans dans ce même dans ce même
manifeste ou dans ce même discours du
sein du gouvernement libanais qui dit
que le liban devrait être neutre
comment on plaide pour la neutralité du
liban et on invite les libanais à
résister contre israël et donc on sait
très bien au liban que quand on appelle
à résister contre israël ça sous-entend
aussi soutenir tous les régimes dans la
région que ce soit le régime iranien
c'est le hezbollah que ce soit le régime
syrien bachar al assad ou autre régime
aussi donc qui sait c'est vraiment c'est
un c'est un coup dur pour la neutralité
du liban
donc ça c'est sur un plan politique sur
le plan financier il ya aucune réforme
concrète qui a été avancé dans ce bilan
ils ont dit que oui ils vont peut-être
adopté quelques conseils dans le plan
mckenzie qui a été proposé l'année
dernière pour sortir de la crise du
liban mais aucune de ces relevés de
réforme n'a été cité dans ce document
sur un autre plan aussi
il y à une adoption claire des mêmes
solutions bien du même plan qui est
appelé le plan boost à nice et le plan
qui gère tout ce qui est énergétiquement
et surtout le secteur de l'électricité
au liban le même plan qui est
responsable de plus de 55 % de la dette
du liban est adopté c'est c'est
scandaleux et c'est indécent justement
concernant l'économie on sait que le
pays est endetté jusqu'au cou une dette
publique sans précédent
quelle solution est ce que l'aide
extérieure voilà pourrait être une chose
pour faire revivre justement cette
économie alors l'aide extérieure ça sera
une aide qui sera qui va aller
directement dans les poches des mêmes
personnes
la d'extérieur si elles ne s'appuient
pas sur des réformes des réformes
concrètes
elle est vaine parce que le liban reçoit
des aides extérieures depuis des années
et des années qui devient la première
éruption revient au problème de la
corruption
on revient aussi à ce système qui est
complètement délétère et qui favorise
même la corruption parce qu'on ne peut
pas oublier que par exemple le port au
liban et tout ce qui est tout ce qui se
rapporte à la douane s'est tenu par de
trois personnes
que ce soit en habit ribéry que ça soit
le hezbollah en parlant du port et de
l'aéroport
walid joumblatt est une figure de la
corruption aussi pendant les années 90
et jusqu'à maintenant même donc le liban
est vraiment captif de plusieurs
personnes qui le tiennent en otage et
qui cherche toujours à alimenter un
certain discours qui dresse les
communautés les unes contre les autres
pour garder cette position de force et
pour pouvoir profiter aussi de tous
c'était pouvoir voler l'argent public
alors vous avez dit craindre justement
que
de tension dans le pays des
affrontements on l'a vu d'ailleurs cet
après midi où les manifestants encore
été délogés par les forces de l'ordre
quelles sont les solutions qui
pourraient apaiser la rue libanaise
alors pour apaiser la rue libanaise il y
à une solution démocratique très
légitime est très logique actuellement
c'est d'organiser des législatives
anticipées
parce qu'on est vraiment dans un cul de
sac sur le plan démocratique le peuple
n'est pas représenté au parlement
mais est ce que il y à vraiment sur le
sur le terrain sur cette scène politique
des personnalités qui pourront
représenter comme il faut le tout à fait
dans la dans la rue libanaise là
actuellement il n'y a pas que des
manifestants venant des classes
défavorisées au liban au contraire il ya
beaucoup de personnes valables il ya des
personnes qui ont des diplômes il ya des
personnes qui ont même des programmes
politiques qui écrivent dans les
journaux on n'oublie pas qu'au liban
enfin le il ya 99% de personnes les
tricks et impayés au le haut le secteur
éducatif très important il est très
évoluée le liban paraît dans les dans
les classements mondiaux sur le engagés
dans le régime perd ici que j'en
qu'engagé dans la vie politique alors ce
n'est pas une priorité pour le moment
parce que justement les revendications
du peuple libanais c'est en premier lieu
de placer des technocrates dans le
gouvernement et même délire des
technocrates au parlement pour sortir de
la crise après on pourrait passer au
discours politique idéologique au
véritable sens du terme très bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup
mayer raddad avoir répondu à la question
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
membre fondateur du forum académique
chrétiens pour la citoyenneté dans le
monde arabe